you've got to be willing to do today
what others don't so you can have
tomorrow
others won't there's only three really
great questions in life who am i
why am i here and what do i do about it
right if you can answer those three
questions you've got purpose
you've got passion and you've got
commitment and you've got to believe in
yourself i mean you've got to
hashtag believe baby you've got to
believe in yourself
ladies and gentlemen steven scoggins in
the house why don't you give a
super quick intro for what you're all
about because i'm a fan of your work
recently discovered you and
want to introduce you to my audience oh
thanks man uh you know
i guess you would call it life mastery
stuff i um i guess the struggle point
came through being homeless and went on
to create six different businesses
um several of them you know large
revenue generating things employ about
400 plus people and
i thought it was about time to give back
um i kind of figured out there's three
great purposes in life serving the
person used to be which i know
you say in a different way but it's like
one of the greatest purposes that you're
ever going to have
yeah and then obviously serving the
person you once loved
and serving the person you wouldn't you
wish you could have saved so you think
about susan b coleman and all these
different organizations stuff like that
um i find that all of our passions kind
of come out of one of those places so i
figured it was time to
hopefully add value to the world and a
big believer in the brand new book man
my team
loves it by the way um it is incredible
dude you did a fantastic job with that
book so well done
cool man thank you well so for those
watching live you can ask us some
questions
uh and for those watching the replay on
the youtube channel uh welcome you get
you get to meet steven scogg is in the
house he's you've got your own youtube
channel too now it's
we did it's getting there it's growing
i'm pumped to see the country you're
putting up there
um cool all right so pop some questions
down below see what we can do
john is writing in to say how do you
dedicate more time to your business
without taking time away from your
family
be intentional yeah so for me one of the
ways that i do that is i try to have a
specific takeaway
so each there's one day a week that is
completely earmarked and put the phone
away
put the computer away and pretty much
focus on time with the family
nothing's more powerful than spending
time with your family because at the end
of the day
if your business happens to struggle or
whatever they're going to be the support
system that's going to carry you through
so that's one of the ways in which i do
it the other thing that i think i do
differently
than a lot of entrepreneurs um is i
segregate it within my calendar
so i i take the time to be intentional
about planning that time out
uh my wife struggled with it at first
because she was like what do you mean
you gotta plan time with me i'm like
well
i want to be intentional like so i don't
want to be distracted i don't want to be
getting phone calls and emails and all
these dings
you know and i think that was one of the
biggest things that i did so
saturdays and sundays are her time the
family's time it's when we go do the fun
stuff and
you know we try to do it we're getting
to build a new house so we know we just
got to doing the design center
selections and stuff like that
and i also make it a point to every
quarter
have one week i take one week every
quarter for me specifically where i go
and dedicate that time
uh to my family to my friends um that
allows us to do that uh you know nina
and whatnot knows that we were in the
mountains last week and i barely
responded any emails or anything you
know i got in trouble when i did but we
you know we spent
half a day building lego sets which was
fun for us so
so to that point it's crazy how people
create a calendar
only for their business conditions and
their business meetings and then that
tends to champ although
all over all the personal stuff so i
love that they've put like gates or
walls around personal time as well to
say no you cannot interrupt me unless
like
everything is burning down or calling or
something
well and the only person that chirped in
was conor who that your team's getting
to know a little bit and then uh he he
got
he got my wife actually text him said
connor it's my time
so it's pretty funny i love it
okay how to know when to quit that was a
hard one for me i don't know how to quit
to be honest it depends on what you're
talking about are you talking life or
you're talking business so in life
there really is nothing better than
being having a persevering spirit right
there's there's nothing better than
being willing to pick yourself back up
after a delay um
you know if i had to listen to my
limiting beliefs and stayed in that
place when i was homeless
then there was no way that i'd ever get
to the place now where hopefully i can
encourage people
how to break three even though even
though their circumstances may not be
quite as dire
some have been there's a greater mission
and a greater story
when you're actually taking the time to
dig deep and keep going um i've learned
that sometimes you don't need to
feel like you have to win every day as
much as you need to just take the time
to win
the hour or the minute right sometimes
you know when i was overcoming
depression one of the things that i
struggled with specifically was the
anxiety that came with it
you know so sometimes i would just kind
of be rewarded with the fact that i got
out of bed
i kind of cleaned myself up like i would
normally go to a job or something like
that and say okay that's a win
you know so it depends on where you're
at where you're coming from when it
comes to business
you know a lot of business ventures uh
will fail
early on because you're learning the
process and one of the ways you can kind
of prevent that is to spend more time
being apprenticed if you will by someone
who's already in that industry or
something like that to kind of prevent
that
i find that one of the greatest things
to do when it comes to looking at a
business perspective
when it's time to quit or when it's time
to pivot i would actually refer to pivot
is are you actually able to carry on
that
carry on that endeavor you know at cost
or for free for a long time if you need
to while you're getting your
infrastructure in place
you know not every business that i've
had has been successful i'll just be
honest with you
i think i've had probably 12 businesses
total and i've only got six that have
been
you know really successful so that's a
good that's a good hit ratio though
that's a good hit
yeah it's 50 you know so but um you know
you got to keep up with that you just
got to you got to have faith
you know you got to dig deep you got you
got you you can't have a quit mentality
you got to see yourself as a warrior one
of the things that i took away
even in your book evan recently was the
quitting
if it's if if you quit now there's no
future for you or the people in the
lives you're supposed to touch
you know you've got to have that moment
where you just keep digging and keep
going to kind of make sure that that
kind of takes place
and you know whether it's life or
whether it's business do you believe in
where you're going
you know that's one thing i love most
about your book is the word believe
right do you believe it and if you don't
believe it can you find the couple
friends that believe in it for you while
you're getting good
at believing in yourself you know my
very first mentor steve byrd
the one of the things i loved about him
is he gave me this quote has been my
lynchpin quote
and he said stephen you have to be
willing to do today what others want
so you can have tomorrow what others
don't
right you got to be willing to do today
what others don't so you can have
tomorrow
others won't for those of you if you
were going to go super far if you were
going to grind
at a super deep level you were going to
have to know that there is a season
where you're kind of hidden in the cleft
of a rock
there's a season when you're unknown no
one knows who you are no one knows what
you're doing
and that hard work that pays that's
hidden becomes the success that becomes
visible to others
when you put in the work so hopefully
that helps
yeah i like it all i would add is i
think you quit when you don't love it
anymore
yeah i think that's a lot of
entrepreneurs stay in businesses or stay
in relationships
longer than they should yeah because
they actually lost their love for
three years ago but they're only
sticking with it out of duty or
dedication or
you know what would people say if i left
this business and then they can't go up
and do something amazing
but if you still love it and you quit
you're going to regret it you're going
to you're going to be
95 looking back what if i just gave it
one more week or one more month right
absolutely that's the test i would use
owen
saying how to not overthink mistakes
well
my two cents and mistakes are what lead
you to success
right so i'm a high school dropout i
never graduated college i never went to
college never graduated high school
and my mistakes are who are what have
taught me
to become successful over time right a
lot of people think that uh i kind of
gave this analogy to one of my sons
recently that
you're building a foundation with a
brick wall where all the all the lines
are super straight and all the bricks
are super nice and like tight and
whatnot
i kind of look at it more like stacked
stone right you're going to have
certain stones that are thin certain
stones that are thick certain stones
that are oblong shaped and stuff like
that
which represent the messiness if you
will
of how to become successful so i think
one of the things that you need to do is
be okay with
quote unquote failing which i don't
believe in i believe it's learning
so either you learn or you win right so
that's i think that's my personal take
on overthinking mistakes if you dwell on
your mistakes
you won't be able to basically
strategize how to move forward
yeah and you look at your content too
one of the things that i pulled out is
that you just don't
get caught up and overthinking anything
yeah
just go and you don't spend time looking
backwards
yeah i think i think we see that across
all the successful people that i've
profiled too it's like you just don't
spend that much time
looking backwards yeah like what am i
doing right now where are we going
that's right it didn't work great next
you'll crash your car if you're looking
in the review mirror
yeah i love it how to push the
depression
and start becoming more persistent
towards your goals
well i can only tell you from experience
what worked for me um
there was a moment when i was in so at
right after i
went from being homeless in a room in my
brother's mobile home that we had
and while i was in that mobile home i
had to get really clear on
what it is i thought i wanted to do or
what i thought it is i needed to become
so one of the most pivotal moments for
me was just having a notepad and a pen
and laying out what would be the perfect
life
if i could actually create it not
knowing if i could or not
right but actually taking the time to
kind of just dream
like what what would it be like to do a
specific thing or be with a specific
person or have a specific thing or
be in a passionate career or something
like that that i loved you know i did
that was my
greatest tool that i used and then i
what i did was i took that same list
of the life that i wanted knowing that i
didn't have it at the time knowing i
didn't have the skill set i didn't have
the teaching i didn't have the
mentorship
i didn't have the education and i
decided to put it up on there on my
mirror
so every single day when i woke up i had
to look at that list
and i had to ask myself did i take a
step today
that was going to lead me towards that
level
right did i actually take a step did i
pick up the phone did i did i go and try
to find a mentor did i
did i read a new book right there's a
term readers or leaders i think
everybody's at least heard of once right
books are powerful right those are
mentors in print
right those are mentors from a
historical nature that have already been
there done that right that i
did i take some time that day and i let
and then what i did was i let my life
build on each individual win
step by step by step by step and then
what happens is you don't really realize
you're coming out of the depression
state or you don't really realize you're
coming out of anxiety or fear
it happens because you're taking a daily
step 365 days in a year if you take a
step every day
you're already gonna be a lot further
along and if you've never taken a step
to begin with so now
why not just take one step
so how did you get over that you're
sitting there and you're you know
you were homeless you're in your
brother's mobile home you write these
things on a mirror how do you get over
the
i can't do that like that goes
me there's no way i can do like i think
that's where a lot of
people will have one day where they
think i can do all these amazing things
and to get rid of it and inspired
i'm gonna go change my life and be a
millionaire or whatever
yeah but then they wake up the next day
it's like i can't do that especially
someone who's depressed like how did you
get out of that
well for me i focused on the tactic like
i focused on the step
i didn't focus on whether or not i
believed i could do it or not i didn't
focus on my limiting beliefs at all
because to be honest i was completely
unsure but i knew if i didn't at least
try
if i didn't at least take a step then i
knew i was never going to get there
you know so i set my goals pretty high i
raised my standard if you will i
i decided that i was going to you know
get up every morning and you know at
five or six a.m and do some workout
just kind of get my blood flowing right
i just changed my behaviors based on the
life that i wanted
and it happened slowly literally a year
later
you don't even realize you're coming out
of depression until you can literally
look back a year later and see it's
happened
right if you focus too much on hey i
feel depressed i feel i feel like i
don't want to
uh play a role in the world if i feel
like you know for there were certain
days i didn't want to get out of bed
like straight up didn't i want to get
out of bed curtains are drawn
dark rooms i don't know how long that
process was but i can tell you that when
i stayed there i knew nothing was going
to change
absolutely knew nothing was going to
change right so if you focus on taking
it just to take a step
and whatever that step is for you if
you've been killing it for a long time
and you've been
kind of been an achiever so to speak
maybe you're going to challenge your
perspective on what really matters maybe
you're going to take the time to
challenge
you know kind of um the perspective that
you're using to
obtain a new skill maybe you're going to
partner with with new people
you know i've learned a lot by watching
a lot of your content recently evan
and that's empowered me and encouraged
me to kind of dream even bigger than
what we've been dreaming as a team here
you know i think you dream big and you
take one step a day
and lo and behold you'll look back like
nobody's business and you'll see that
you've actually come incredibly far
and when you're that at that place right
once you become someone new now you can
go back and serve the person you used to
be so maybe you focus on serving the
person you used to be
rather than just trying to become
something different right maybe there's
a greater purpose there's something
better and bigger to go after
yeah i think surrounding yourself with
people who have come out of it
even like i've never been depressed
i've had anxiety i've had problems but
i've never been like would never say i
was depressed
so i may not be a good role model for
you but
stephen has and and he was
homeless and lived out of his brother's
you know mobile home
and now has 400 employees right
and so if i'm you i i subscribe to
steven's youtube channel
like this video is what is it every day
are you daily now yeah so we're posting
a video every single day
uh well five days a week not every
single day so we take two days off
because we have to edit
right right right so but like in looking
at that it's like hey here's someone
who's exactly like me
who's come out on the other side and i
want a mindset like him like how did how
did you make that shift
and and there's always i mean you have
so many videos and so many stories that
you're sharing like if that was me
if i've been homeless or i'm depressed
right now i find guys like you and i'm
and i'm consuming their content every
day to say
huh like it's possible if you can do it
maybe i can do and just that seed of
hope
can be the thing that keeps you going
did you have something like that that
you looked at and said
this is what i want to become you know
we didn't have the internet when i when
i first started digging out but what i
did have is i did have steve meyer
and i did have susan batts who the world
will probably never know about with
exception of what i when i'm on a stage
somewhere i can talk about
the impact that they made to me right
steve
susan bass talked me from uh talked me
off from taking my life and steve myer
taught me business skills and he taught
me
um relational skills he he taught me to
dream bigger than my circumstances
because had i followed my circumstances
i would have probably stayed in this
the same place in the same state right
uh i forgot who actually originated the
quote but show me your five friends i'll
show you your future
right you gotta choose our choose those
relationships well
um we talked about on one of the videos
we had called something called the
mentorship matrix
right there's four areas that right now
in this day and age that you can
actually get
mentorship right there's a one-to-one
relationship like i had with steve
there's the historical which comes out
of books and
stuff like that there's the digital side
that comes out of like videos and
podcasts and things of that nature right
all right and then there's what's called
a co-star there's somebody that comes
alongside of you that's
that's kind of in the same place maybe
they're a little head but like a
ping-pong partner
like we can balance ideas off of right
well maybe this is the right direction
maybe this is the right direction
there's a conversation
that conversation breeds new thought
which breeds new action which brings new
results
i love it and i think there's also the
evolving i don't think consider this a
digital mentor but for people
like if you go live on instagram people
can ask you questions and you can bring
them in
like this they may not ever have that
opportunity to come and
see you and talk to you and your busy
guy but they can spend five minutes
seven minutes with you on instagram live
and actually it's not just a digital
like i'm learning from afar but like hey
i got one question i can ask it to
stephen here it is
that opportunity never existed before so
no it hasn't
your heroes are going live go go try to
connect with them yeah and you know
through some of your mentorship that's
actually something we'll be looking to
do here in the near future
so i think you would crush it dude oh my
god like a daily instagram live i mean i
do two o'clock every day i think i think
it'd be great
well thanks man well i got uh christian
over here in the corner with me from our
from our uh
graphic design team so she's ready to
kind of make sure we uh get that in
place as soon as possible
all right christian let's go you know
like at the beginning what i would do
this is what i did too at the beginning
i scheduled all of my people who are
coming on
because i was just going to my audience
and so like look at how many people
already follow you
and say hey i'm doing a new daily show
whether it's 10 minutes 15 minutes 25 i
go 25 minutes but
um i booked my first five guests and
would you like to have a free 25 minute
one-on-one with me on my instagram live
yeah right like from all your followers
for anybody watching too you don't need
to have
thousands you have 100 followers you'll
get five people who will say yes
right and yeah then you start building
it up and training them that hey two
o'clock eastern every day i'm going
live and then people will want to join
like we're doing text questions now but
people will
they're people are putting up their
hands like hey can i come in live next
right and that and that'll be
you and you being able to see their eyes
light up
to say like you've helped them right the
person you used to be you're helping
them and serving them
um it's tremendous value but also great
content for
instagram but also cutting up for your
youtube channel well you also get a
sense of who they are and what their
needs are
right so i mean our heart is to be
sincere there's a lot of um
people in the sp in the space that are
you're trying to cut through the noise
and you're trying to do things well and
you're trying to do things right
but we have a sincere heart i would do
this for free like i don't have any like
this is
steve myrick taught me the power of
creating a legacy by helping someone
just
understand more about themselves
understand more about where they want to
go
and understand more about how to get
there right if you think about it
there's only three really great
questions in life who am i
why am i here and what do i do about it
right if you can answer those three
questions you've got purpose you've got
passion and you've got commitment
and then it's just about not giving up i
love it guys you gotta go watch
on youtube there's tons of value there
okay next question popping up here how
do you stop yourself from telling
your loved ones all the ideas as they
come
so i may not be the best one for
answering this question but i'll give it
a go
i'm an idea machine yeah so i love
producing content i love doing great
things
um there are a couple different things
that i do i my
i share a lot of concepts with my team
first my wife's second i know that
sounds crazy
but my wife is designed to keep me
grounded right so there's certain things
that she'll challenge me on a little bit
and say hey maybe
it's not that it's too big but maybe it
needs to be looked at again
and then i actually use this this pesky
device that we're on today called an
iphone and i actually have to keep an
idea folder note
so when i'm at the gym i'm typically
doing a lot of um
mobility stuff and whatnot you know and
my brain's firing
right so i wrote an entire um not a
script per se but some of the concepts
that i want to share in our upcoming
video taping on thursday
right and i try to use that as my idea
folder so but i have an idea about every
10 seconds
i mean i'm an entrepreneur's
entrepreneur i did a strengthsfinder
years ago and
strengthsfinder basically said if you
were anything other to be an
entrepreneur you'd have big problems
right because of that so i use an idea
folder um i use my what i call my board
of directors right these are people that
i'm like i sit down with connor and a
christian and evan and
you know our evan including and then
you're evan right
and i say hey what do you think about
this and this they either say hey look
you know it's gonna it's i would do this
i would do that um kind of thing so you
know those are some of the things that i
think
that would be helpful i think just being
honest with yourself and then oh
i got a this is one that was hard for me
to break sorry a bonus one
yeah like don't tie your identity to
someone not seeing the full vision or
the full thing
one of the biggest mistakes that i made
in trying to get myself together and get
myself to a place where i could actually
um be successful in my what i
what i deemed a success was if someone
if i had an idea and they immediately
shot it down i immediately gave up
okay certain people especially if
they're in a season where they are
i want to say that i don't want to say
this rude that i don't know where i say
it so please forgive me
if you have a small mind it's hard to
understand big ideas
okay so if you're stuck in a situation
where you have a big
big concept a big idea something
powerful something good
that you really want to pursue then try
balancing that stuff off of someone else
that maybe is either already where you
want to go or somebody who's in
at least in the in the running lane to
get there
now you do need people in your life to
bounce ideas off of that are going to be
people who can keep you grounded and
watch out for your blind spots one of
the things we talk a lot about on our
channel
is strength struggles and blind spots
right you got strengths that are your
natural gifts
you got struggles things that you don't
do as well like i saw because i'm
dyslexics right so i can't
i have to write an email like 15 times
or have someone write it for me in many
cases
right and then you got the blind spots
those are the areas that you never see
coming
right you need people covering your sex
right so when you go to produce an idea
don't tie your identity to it i mean in
other words
it may pivot it may change some but get
people that
deserve the time then and the presence
to be there
the space to help you shape that idea
you know we're gonna you know we talked
about doing this massive live event that
we've done over the last couple of years
until covet happened
and that live video was crazy successful
what i had to do to get my team on board
is i literally wrote out an entire uh
blog or essay if you will
being as descriptive as i could possibly
be from the person's perspective who was
going to sit in that seat
and the team knew i was receiving the
team knew i was well i was serious when
i couldn't stop crying when i was
reading it
so maybe change the approach don't tie
your identity to it and choose the right
people to share it with
yeah i think i mean that's the problem
for a lot of people who are starting up
is that they have nobody to talk to
like they could say oh stephen that's
great now you got a team and 400 people
and all this stuff but like
at the beginning where there's nobody to
talk to and you tell your parents to
your friends and they think you're crazy
and they say
no just go get a job
like what do you do in that scenario do
you just keep it to yourself like you've
got
nobody to talk to do you go find
somebody don't just don't yeah i mean so
you know before youtube and stuff like
that i would talk about
big visions or big ideas with people who
are already on the path
i learned a long time ago that if your
circumference of influence
is happy where they're at you know call
it misery loves company or whatever if
they're happy where they're at
they're not going to be prone to help
you or believe you believe in that idea
the first person has to believe in
anything and you said this best in your
book is you
you got to believe it's worth it you got
to believe the sacrifice is worth it you
got to believe that
going the extra mile is worth it even
when you don't see the evidence
because so much of success comes from
the stuff that that happened five years
earlier
right so much of success comes from
there and you've got to believe in
yourself i mean you've got to
hashtag believe baby you got to believe
in yourself you know what i'm saying
i agree there i'm not going to speak
about that i love it
cool well man it's crazy how quickly
time flies when you're having fun
um you definitely need to be doing this
like i think you'll crush it i think
especially if you bring people in
because
the question that they ask is is a
surface level question too and you'll
just get to the core super quick when
you're
with somebody face to face but for
people watching who want to dive deeper
into your world either here
live on the replay or youtube where do
you want them to go uh
you know hit hit obviously visit youtube
if you haven't already uh
feel free to follow us here on instagram
we'd love to have you and especially we
get ready to these questions ourselves
and then uh
journeyprinciples.com thank you man i'm
so pumped for your journey what you're
doing the good you're pumping out and um
i'm super excited to see you blow up
with everything you're doing too
i appreciate it man thank you so much i
believe everything you guys are doing
your team is just amazing dude
you probably already know that but shout
out to those guys because they're
killing it
i love it thank you man talk to you all
right buddy see you take care bye
if you want to see the one-on-one i did
with tony robbins check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there